[Music]
thanks for joining our session it's been
an amazing week this week here in San
Francisco
so before we start the session I'm happy
to tell you a little bit about do it
international
my name is the fatty and I and I'm a
partner manager at Google cloud based in
Tel Aviv part of my role is to work with
partners like do it international in lbm
to succeed in bring the best out of
Google cloud twelve short customers and
do it international was founded in 2010
by a smaller number of software
engineers that actually understood in
early stages that App Engine which is
the first Google cloud product it can
bring lots of value to startups
and AB startup to focus on their main
business on sites application window
rather than investing in maintenance and
infrastructure and since then they did
lots of implementation with many
customers using App Engine and of course
some other products and leveraged the
Google cloud solutions and do it a
became a good doing the u.s. do it we do
it international became a global partner
of Google cloud they are they are very
active in Israel USA in also Europe and
and they are doing lots of a a project
and implementation large-scale customers
and bringing the best as I said for
Google cloud to our customers in part in
addition to a great professional
services and support to our customers do
it are very active and contribute to the
open-source community by developing lots
of open-source tools and just go quickly
on some of them to get you a sense of
examples one of them is the shamash
which is auto-scaling a tool for a
manager Dupin day spa Google many of the
Dupin spark and other good example is a
xariah which is
um schedule that for a scheduler for a
[Music]
schedule for a compute engine which can
give a customer's actually to use a this
product and it's an open source of
course and sometimes we'd use the array
infrastructure cost up to 60% of non
production environment and the most
famous one is reoptimize we optimizes a
open source tool open source platform
for cost optimization it is also
available in Google marketplace and it
helps customer to get a better view of
their workload and usage of their cloud
and do optimization of their costs and
there are so many other tools and we
will cover some of them during this
session
and I'm happy now to invite to stage
Vadim solavei who is the founder of do
of do it and the CTO welcome buddy
thanks a lot for the great introduction
I guess I couldn't do better myself so
hello everyone we're gonna have let me
quickly catch up here on things ok so
during our session today I'm going to
tell you a customer story some mutual
project that we had together with a
company called jelly button-- so for
these people who do not know jelly
button-- is a gaming companies they
produce mobile games and one of the most
famous games is called pirate kings so
pirate kings have over a hundred million
active users worldwide people who play
the game on their iOS or Android device
and today we are going to talk about how
jelly button-- have replaced their event
analytics pipeline based on the solution
that I'm going to present you right now
and it's not a big secret that most
people when they want to deploy some
sort of the event analytics pipeline or
platform they start with the
off-the-shelf products right and there
are so many available solutions on the
market products such as Mixpanel or
segments or even Google Analytics or
KISSmetrics and so many others and don't
get me wrong all of those solutions are
excellent and they definitely have their
own market however this session will
focus on how you can build your own
event analytics platform and why would
you do that you may ask well usually
it's because the of the shelf platforms
they won't be as flexible as you'd like
or sometimes they have a very high cost
and the cost is usually some sort of the
per event price that you pay usually
it's gradually decreasing over volume
like as many as you have more events you
will probably pay a little bit less
however it's a certain scale the price
can go up as high as tens of thousands
of dollars per month and in that case
and the jelly button-- case specifically
they were spending between forty five to
sixty five thousand dollars per month on
their of the Shelf event oolitic
analytics platform depending on the how
popular their game was on a certain
months and finally another problems that
usually exists with the off-the-shelf
solution is they don't allow you to
easily own your own data meaning that
making it accessible and available to
your other systems and services and for
example you can't use your own bi tool
of choice and you will have to use the
charting and reporting engine this is
part of the of the Shelf tool and you
can't give your data analyst
inability to query your data using
standard sequel and usually you will
need to use some sort of a proprietary
language and there are many more
examples why those systems can be a
little bit limiting sometimes so for a
couple of years jelly button-- were
using the off-the-shelf analytics
platform to the point that it wasn't
longer financially feasible and the
flexibility wasn't good enough so jelly
button-- has decided to build a new
system and the design principle of that
new system would be it has to be
flexible in a way that it will allow
them to analyze their data in any way
they would like using standard sequel or
any bi tool of choice it should be cheap
to build operate and maintain over time
and it should have much better economy
of scale comparing to the off-the-shelf
solution that they had and finally it
has to be global since there are players
anywhere in the world they wanted the
events to be sent with the lowest
latency possible and so based on all of
those design goals we came up with the
following high-level architecture of
their own event analytics pipeline and
let me walk you through this
architecture as a high-level before we
are going to deep dive into the
specifics of each and every part so
first we have the ingestion part this is
where we get the events from mobile
devices and processing in general there
are two distinct types of events one
type are the events being sent from the
game itself from the mobile device for
example users logging in going from one
level to the other or accumulating stars
or doing in-app purchases
another kind of the event are the events
generated by the gaming back-end these
are more system level events and usually
they are good indicators of the overall
platform health the next big part is the
event processing this is where we
validate the events parse them store
them for future analysis this is also
where we calculate certain metrics such
as leaderboards or enriching the events
with the other data such as game
location of users for example and
finally the last piece is where we
generate the reports and allow the data
scientists to analyze the events so now
let's take a closer look at the event
ingestion part so to ingest the events
we need to have some sort of the restful
api with which our mobile sdk can
communicate and send the events right
and we have written an initial version
of the our API in ogs and we have
decided to run it on top of the
kubernetes or specifically gke which is
the google manage kubernetes so you may
ask why have we choose Jiki - to run our
api well we have considered other
options such as compute engine for
example but we wanted something more
managed so we wouldn't be bothered with
things like auto scaling or monitoring
or doing version upgrades of our
software we have also considered App
Engine
which is the Google platform as a
service which we have used many many
times in the past four hours for our
other solutions however App Engine as of
today while it has some really beautiful
tools for seamless deployments and auto
scaling it is a little bit limited to
only one geographical region and we
wanted to have multiple endpoints in
many places
and in multiple geographies so finally
the reason that we have used the G key
is because G key have give gave us
exactly the features we needed fully
managed infrastructure on one hand but
with an ability to run multiple clusters
in different ridges regions while being
able to deploy a single version of our
API and we are using features such as
horizontal positive scaling to control
the number of API pods running according
to the amounts of the event per second
that we are getting and also the G key
node autoscaler which is a automatically
increases so decreases the number of
nodes as in accordance with the amount
of the pods that we are running at the
same time and on top of that we are also
using a really nice feature called
cluster Federation so cluster Federation
is essentially a kubernetes feature
which gives you an ability to build I
was I would like to say like a super
cluster so you can have multiple
clusters every cluster can be in a
different region or even a different
cloud provider or on premises but you
can still manage all of those clusters
from a single control plane and it's a
very powerful feature as you can imagine
because I can have my API running just
anywhere in the world but still
controlling everything from a single
from a single place and finally the
other very important piece here is the
Google HTTP load balancer so we are
using something that called global ap
which allow us to have a single anycast
IP address for our API and the requests
that is being sent from the mobile
device is resolving that IP address to
the nearest locations that Google has in
the same region and that's done
automatically for you
so initially we had a couple of clusters
one in the North America and the other
one in Western Europe but eventually we
have added more clusters in the other
places as well just to cover them so to
summarize that point we have a single AP
all of the events are being sent to that
single IP the IP is being resolved to a
local cluster in the region that is
geographically close to the end user
player and then the API processes the
event and pushes it forward so just to
give you a good example of how having a
local cluster in certain geographies
improves over latency let's first take a
look on the median latency for North
America or Western Europe so it's 89
milliseconds and 54 milliseconds for for
Europe however as you can see for
players in asia-pacific without the
local clusters there the latency was on
a scale of 250 milliseconds almost 5
times I'm sorry five times longer than 4
players in geographies where we have
local clusters but thanks to the
kubernetes figuration it was very easy
for us to add another cluster in
asia-pacific and that immediately
brought down the latency to just sixty
one millisecond which is almost 75
percent improvement and we didn't have
to change anything to support this
additional cluster the IP of our API
stays exactly the same thanks to the
global IP feature we didn't have to
update the mobile application just
because we edit a new cluster and once
we have the cluster up and running under
the Federation the kubernetes pushed the
latest version of our API to that
cluster and the Google HTTP load
balancer started to route in new
requests coming from Asia Pacific to
that new local cluster
and as there will be more players in
other regions it will be as seamless for
us to add additional clusters in the
same way over time another piece of
technology we are using here is a Google
Cloud endpoints we obviously have to
protect the API from unauthorized use
and we are using Cloud endpoints to
provide additional features that we just
didn't want to develop ourselves and
rather prefer to rely on Google so we're
using Cloud endpoints to provide us with
the authentication rate control and
monitoring and let me put a little bit
more context here so of course
authentication is important because we
don't want unauthorized devices or BOTS
to send us engineering data and by using
Cloud endpoints we ensure that only
devices providing the correct
authentication token can send us the
event data rate control is another very
important thing because even while
unauthenticated bots they cannot send
the data because they do not have as
they talking they can still make
attempts to send the data and if there
is enough of them it will be some sort
of the denial of service attack right
causing us to spend extra money on more
resources such as kubernetes nodes or
network egress traffic and finally Cloud
endpoints provides many additional
features such as monitoring our API we
can version the API and maybe most
importantly it can automatically
generate the Mobile SDK for iOS and
Android so once we reintroduce a change
to our API we can automatically generate
the SDK and use that as decay in our
next version of the game now that we are
almost done with the API part itself the
final but very important part is the
Google pub/sub so in general we are
using pops up to temp
temporarily store our vendata that we
are getting from the devices pub/sub is
a managed sort of message bus which
essentially means that we can create a
topic it's a little bit similar to I
would say water pipe and then to send
the data from one side of that pipe to
the to the other side and in our case we
are using pub/sub because it's a good
practice to build systems in a way where
the communication between different
parts of our system will be synchronous
in that way we can scale the different
parts separately one formula from the
other and also if some part is under
load or a pressure or even down we are
not losing any data so we are getting
the event from the API running on
kubernetes and we are putting that event
into the pub/sub so let's see what
happens next so after the ingestion part
is done we are getting into the event
processing so what do I mean by event
processing event processing it's
actually many things that we need or
have to do to allow effective analysis
of the data so first we need to parse
the events and then we need to make sure
they are complete and valid usually
after that we will want to enrich our
data for example one of the most popular
enrichments are Gale location based on
the IP address of the request we would
like to know the city country perhaps
some other data of the player and after
enrichment we are grouping and
aggregating the data because sometimes
we would like to store different events
in different tables in our database I
will get to that a little bit later
and we also want to calculate some
metrics on the fly so for example think
of the leader board so we want to
display a leaderboard on our website to
see how many stars every player has so
one way of doing that would be to store
everything in some database and then
make some queries over the data and
let's say refresh them every minute or
something what we are doing here we are
actually calculating the leaderboard on
the fly at the time that we process the
events and that's in a that's pretty
cool right
so for event processing we are using
Apache beam it's an open-source project
originated from Google several years ago
and now it's a part of Apache foundation
well specifically in our case we are
using Google Cloud dataflow which is a
managed version of the Apache beam so we
wouldn't need to worry about deploying
our own servers or scaling them or
monitoring them according to the volume
of the data that we are receiving and
Google Cloud dataflow is basically a
cloud-based version of the ETL of the
extract transform load paradigm and with
dataflow we can read the data from this
from a certain source parse the data
transform it aggregated group it and
finally send it to another destination
and you can write the Google data flow
pipelines or jobs in Java or Python and
it has a long list of supported
connectors to various Google cloud
products such as pub/sub or bigquery or
big table or spanner or cloud sequel and
so many others and if you'd like you can
even use a patchy beam and run your jobs
on external data processing engines such
as spark or flink
which means it gives you the freedom of
running your workloads just anywhere
without any kind of a vendor lock-in and
this was something that was very
important for us because we wanted to
give that freedom and to be able to
basically run it everywhere if so which
is so in our case we are reading the
data from the Google pub/sub we are
parsing the data we are doing the
aggregation and groupings and finally
sending the data to the Google bigquery
and BigTable for for further analysis so
the code that you are seeing right now
is a kind some kind of a pseudo code
because the actual code while it looks
like very similar it's a little bit more
verbose because you know Java is pretty
verbose language so I just couldn't fit
it to put it on the slide but you get
the idea and the Apache beam SDK is a
very powerful in a sense that you can
write a very complicated code you can
have a very complicated pipeline but you
can like your code is very short and
once you deploy your code as a Google
data flow will automatically build a
graph which you can see on the right
side of of the slide so that graph is
being automatically generated from your
code you will see that on the Google
cloud console along some monitoring
information on how your pipeline is
performing meaning for example how many
events you're processing what is the
delay of the event or in other words how
much time does it take to process a
single event from a second it's being
read from the Google pub/sub until to
the point that is being pushed to the
Google bigquery and then you can monitor
those metrics and build some sort of
alerts so you can be notified if your
pipeline is performing worse than you
would expect
and here's the actual graph by the way
for the demos that we will be showing
shortly so in that graph you can see
that we are reading a people data
actually it's an information about our
users and the event data which are the
actual events like login or moving from
one level to the other and then we are
doing the parsing and aggregations and
essentially finally we are pushing the
data to several destinations in our case
it's a big query in BigTable and I will
get to that in I think just one minute
and since we are using streaming
pipelines with Apache beam the time
window notion is extremely important
here if you are constantly reading the
data from some streaming source such as
Google pops up for example and you want
to build aggregations on the fly time
windows are essential to be able to do
that so Google dataflow will
automatically sign every vent to a
correct time window based on the
semantic event time which means the true
time when the event actually happened as
opposed to the time that event was
received by the data flow now with every
part is in the correct time window it is
very simple to count for example to
count the amount of stars each player
has to to calculate through the world
and to update that in real time and
there are many supported window types in
gold at afloat for example fixed windows
sliding windows session windows or even
custom windows if none of the standard
window types doesn't work for you and
windows are also really helpful for
taking care of the late events for
example you can imagine that you are
playing the game but you are in the
elevator or you are in the place where
you have a limited network coverage and
in that case even if you are more
device generate the events those events
are not being sent because you don't
have the network and sometimes it can
take a lot of time to actually fund
sends those events it can be minutes it
can be even hour sometimes if you're
taking flight for example and one of the
greatest things with the Google data
flow or Apache beam in that sense is
that have the notion of the late events
so while the event can really arrive
late by any amount of time it can still
be assigned to the correct window to the
correct time window so we can correctly
recalculate our leaderboards at every
given time and there are many
innovations available with Apache beam
to point acts and the latest version is
2.5 and those features for example our
dynamic destinations they can help you
to send your data to very various tables
based on the arbitrary data that you are
receiving or for example automatic
schema detections making your life so
much easier by not having to hard-code
your schemas into the code into the
Python code that you're producing and
the other really important part here is
the data mutability so the data
mutability as you can as it sounds it
means that some data can change over
time and this may be a little bit
difficult with analytical databases such
as Google bigquery which are attend only
by their nature but what if you you have
a table of the players and you want to
update the player information for
example on the fly well you may want to
update each player's with its current
status of the amount of stars that they
have or their cash balance
and this is why we have opted to use
both Google bigquery for immutable data
data that doesn't change such as events
with big table for the mutable data such
as player table and Google using Google
Cloud dataflow we are sending those
events directly to the bigquery making
it's available for later analysis by
data scientists and our BI tools and for
those people who doesn't know BigTable
is no sequel database powering some
really popular applications such as
Gmail or AdWords here at Google and it's
ideal for storing sparse information
such as in our example people's profiles
and it can support millions of updates
every second BigTable is managed which
means once again we don't need to be
bothered with management by ourselves
and now that we are done with the event
processing let's talk a little bit about
the event analytics so for internal it
excusing Google bigquery so this is a
high level of the bigquery architecture
one of the greatest thing about the
bigquery is that it has storage and
compute scaled independently on demand
it helps us to analyze billions of daily
events using standard sequel at the
great speed most of our queries are
running only a few seconds despite the
fact that they scan terabytes of the
data and since last year Google bigquery
allows you not only to query native
tables but also for the federated tables
and federated tables that means that you
they can reside on other storage systems
such as BigTable for example
and since BigTable itself is a no sequel
database it means you cannot run complex
queries on it right
however with Google bigquery and
federated tables you can have the power
of both BigTable and bigquery by being
able to run the really complicated
sequel queries
over no sequel data and if you can still
remember at the beginning of my talk I
barely Canon myself
you may recall that we wanted the event
analytics platform to be very cost
effective and I also said that the of
the shell solution that jelly button--
were using has a significant cost of the
tens of thousands of dollars every month
so let's take a short look on how much
does it cost us today to run the system
that I have just presented so we are
using reoptimize Ayoo for google cloud
analytics it's available from do it
international for free it's a pretty
sophisticated tool that have some cost
analytics and cost optimization platform
and what you can see here on the slide
is one of the cost control dashboards
and so you can see how much we are
spending on Google cloud every month and
some break down by specific product over
time so in July 2017 when we launched
the new system we were processing about
1.3 billion of daily events and the
overall cost of the Google cloud for us
was on the scale of $1500 per month
that's all in January 2018 we were
ingesting and processing 3.3 billion
events it's about three times more and
our cost was just about $2,000 per month
and finally during May 2018 just few
months ago we were already processing
six million six billion I'm sorry of
daily events and still is our cost is a
little bit less than actually a little
bit more than $3,000 right so if you
compare that to the 45 to 65 thousand
dollars that we were paying every month
before that that's a pretty significant
cost saving right
you can clap thank you guys so it took
us about five weeks of three people to
build the new system we have spent about
two weeks exploring different
architectures and prototyping before we
could settle on the current state of
affairs then we took another week to
make our quad production ready another
week of testing everything in parallel
to running the previous system and
finally over the course of the fifth
week we have gradually moved all of our
event analytics traffic to the new
system and right now I would like to
call your own customer a liability
engineer at do-it international for the
demo thank you for doing hi everybody so
we are all familiar with the common flow
in which data is coming to pub/sub and
from there we take it using data flow
doing whatever we want to do with it and
putting it into big query since this is
the obvious thought then I'm going to
show a little bit about what you are
doing with BigTable and why is it more
dynamic and more interesting so as but
instead last year Google announced the
federated queries which allows you to
run SQL queries on unstructured data
like that resides on BigTable this
allows us to run the same SQL queries on
virtual tables on bigquery that actually
belongs to BigTable so what we got was
two requests were two requests in the
latest version the first one was to
create a dynamic middle board for bigger
amount of users something that
will not be calculated in data flow but
will be taken outside and the second
thing was to be able to remove a user
from the system according to the GDP our
compliance guidelines to solve this we
decided to actually put BigTable into
the flow and to split the data according
to the need so we have three types of
data we have the users which contains
the PII we have the events which doesn't
contain any PII and the little ball
again doesn't contain any PRI so I want
to this is a part very small part of the
of the pipeline in data flow I just want
you to feel a little bit about what we
are doing we actually have two main
flows we have the one on the left that
actually takes data from people messages
that are coming to the people topic on
pub/sub it's doing all kind of fancy
enrichment depends again on the game and
the requirements and from there directly
to BigTable now I want to let's see a
little bit about what we have on
BigTable so actually a big table we have
two tables we have the leader board and
we have the people now if I want to see
one of the users for example on BigTable
then I will probably do something like
this and I will get all the history of
the user to the people who don't know
BigTable actually gives us kind of
three-dimensional a table so we have not
only the columns and the family names we
also have the time period a time series
of data pair each row but this is not
something which is that easy to utilize
so what we did was actually to define
the same table using this JSON to take
this JSON and to put it into BigTable
and define the Federated external table
the bigquery table sorry the big table
table on bigquery I have too many bigs
and too many tables my apologies sorry
you have to do something about it
so actually this is the schema of the
people table data that resides on big
table as it represents on bigquery now
from here if I want to do the same query
on the same user it's relatively easy
and of course I can see in one line who
is the user what is this age gender
again I defined over here that I want to
see only the latest version of each of
the columns
since it's a sparse data I will get only
the relevant data that exists the latest
version over here
so I want to go back to the second flow
and now the second flow is actually the
more interesting one the way I see it
because the second flow takes all the
messages that are event related so it
listen to a different topic on pub/sub
it takes all the data the all the
messages that arrive and it's it will do
four things with these messages the
first one store the role message into
bigquery and I didn't made a mistake
over here directly to bigquery this is
actually the single source of truth the
customer can do whatever analytics on
the bigquery using the Big Valley engine
it will run fast and will have all the
advantages of bigquery the second part
of the flow will take the event the same
event now we will do some kind again of
any fencing enrichment and it will
update or actually insert new records
into two tables the first one is to the
people table this way I don't have to
calculate outside of BigTable the status
of each of each user once I entered new
row or new value for each of these they
cashed a stars and cash a the user will
automatically will have the only the
latest version that we entered the
second thing is the leaderboard now when
I'm doing this I actually don't need
BigTable to handle all the windowing and
splitting and keeping the letter
arrivals not only that when I'm doing
windowing on weon on data flow that I
need to define a windows time periods a
early firing over here the data is up to
date all the time
again we are utilizing the very fast
respond a millisecond or sub millisecond
response of BigTable so a let's look a
bit into the tables so what we did was
to take the leader board I want to start
first of all with the more trivial one
which is the the immutable events again
this is a very standard big very a tape
table native bigquery table I'm sure
that you're all familiar with so I will
continue to the next one which is the
leader board this is the one that is
more interesting this is the table that
will exist physically on big table but
we represented it using this JSON this
is very small JSON of I want to know
only the star balance and the cash
balance per user a the key that we used
over here was actually the date and the
user ID now if I want to query for a
specific date I want to see let's say I
want to say who are the five leaders for
the it's not what it 24th because I just
change the query today to the 25th so as
you can see I have the key from the key
I got the user ID and I know exactly how
much a star balance and cash balance in
this case I ordered it according to the
star balance because usually this is
what we care now if somebody from a
marketing program or from cells want to
better understand who are the best
spenders or leaders for a period of time
I can always go and also do the row
between and then give a date range or a
key range and according to this key
range get all the relevant data
that reside inside this range in this
case I did from the 22nd today and I got
a different list of people this time
they are sorted by the cash balance now
again think about the fact that all this
data actually reside in BigTable a this
is something that was not possible using
CBT or any other a common tools working
with BigTable but once we are working
with bigquery and federated the tables I
can do this without any problem now the
last thing that we still have is how we
remove the user so again doing it with
bigquery was a bit more complicated here
if I have this user all I have to do is
delete row and that's it hopefully the
god of demo will not do anything and yes
he's out one last thing before I finish
a dim spoke about part of the date of
the flow that we did this is today it's
the bonniest which is the one of the
operations that we are speaking about
that we presented earlier so you can
play with it and get 80 to 90% of the
flow already that's it thank you
[Applause]
thanks Yoram so just one thing before
before we end the session today so if
you are like jelly button and you are
looking to build your own event
analytics pipeline
banes based on the principles that we
explain during that session we have some
great news after implementing that
analytics Python solution for many other
customers in the last year we have
decided to open source that so you have
the whole solution and the whole
blueprint publicly available on the
github so it's kind of like a beanie
ated based on our experience as best
practices event analytics pipeline
supporting elastic schemas and you can
get going just in a couple of hours so
just clone the repository and of course
feel the issue if you if you need some
help and well some references you will
get them I guess when you access that
presentation on the Google web site but
there are some useful resources that we
thought it would be great sharing them
with you if at thank you very much Vadim
in your home for great presentation and
I hope you all enjoy it and what one
last thing I wanted to say about a do it
I don't know if you're all aware but
during this week here in San Francisco
we had the partner and summit and do it
one third time in a wall indigo in the
global award or for it's a certain
engineering excellence so I think they
deserve a place for that as well
[Applause]
you
[Music]